just to warn you the report includes
references to suicidal thoughts
and anxiety
okay mate yes how are you doing
i think it's number one isn't it this is
nathan
he's 14. when he was six his dad died
the trauma caused by his dad's death has
more recently led him to have
seizures but it's not a physical medical
condition
it's a rare psychological condition
nathan also gets anxious and sometimes
he thinks about taking his own life
well my mental health can go up and down
all over the place it's been like a
roller coaster really
i lost my dad when i was six years old
and
i just wanted to be with him so
i've had like suicidal thoughts
when i get to that stage i know
something's happened
and that's when i can talk to my mum my
stepdad
basically anyone nathan's mum joe has
fought hard
to get her son the help he needs
sometimes i blame myself
i do put on a brave face because it's
really
it can be tough at times because you
just want to do what's right as a mum
and some
and when it's something like this it's
like i can't help him
one in six youngsters suffer from a
mental health problem
it can be a daily battle if it goes
untreated
you're going to order our stuff
and you're going to pay because that's
one of the things that
you worry about mental health nurse
nicole renshaw
is trying to help 15 year old macy she
suffers from anxiety
and she's trying to overcome one of her
biggest fears
going into a shop well if you do this
today
you've conquered all your things yeah
why did you want to conquer it so i can
do it and it's not like
scary so i can actually do things on my
own right there's my card
i want you to go in get me a drink you
would drink
and as a snack so i'm outside if you
need anything
macy is so anxious that she needs some
support
to do something most of us take for
granted
i can't do it
that's not mine can you get
nicole i can't
i think it was a mountain to climb for
us
so we have got past one hurdle of that
situation
you did really well then it's okay
first times are nerve-wracking and i
think because it was busy
we will do it time and time again until
she feels comfortable
to do that on her own
okay are you ready are you going in the
round then yeah
and then i'll come back out and get your
jokes all right
[Music]
nathan is being treated by consultant
clinical child psychologist dr chantel
bassin
they just told us that
she's trying to help him make sense of
his dad's death
and his own mental health i was here
yep now i'm here and what's been the
difference between getting from here up
to here
um i don't know i think it like i've
been feeling happy quite
a lot this morning and i think it's just
because like
it's like come on when i can come and
talk to someone
that can drink that i can trust and
stuff like that
that might they can help me so i think
that's a massive difference
oh that's really lovely to hear and i'm
very honored to be able to do that
he's made massive progress he really has
over a short space of time
um because he's so emotionally
intelligent so
so intelligent so eloquent he's really
been able to examine those traumas
what we've said that we'll look at is
a way of holding his dad inside him
what is it about joe that brings tears
for you because that's all i want
that's awesome i don't want him to
for youngsters struggling with their
mental health the right kind of support
is essential
with services under increasing pressure
it's never been more crucial
nick martin sky news